I
good afternoon my name is NaN heartless
and I'm the director of the emeritus
college I want to welcome you to what
promises to be a fascinating
conversation among a group of women who
are part of the story of Emory
University I want to acknowledge that
there are a number of individuals and
organizations who have helped to make
this event possible you will see some of
those in the programs that I hope you
have picked picked up in addition I want
to especially thank Gary Hulk in the
office of the president and the founding
director of the center for women Ali
crown and the current director donor
Yarborough each of these people have
provided encouragement to us and often
at the time when we needed encouragement
most the discussion for the afternoon
are part of a living history project of
the emeritus college which chronicles
and documents the experiences of
emeritus faculty and administrators
within the life of the university since
the conversation is being taped we will
have a permanent record of what is said
here today and this tape will serve as a
resource for all of us and also for
generations of learners who will follow
us as a reminder may I gently say please
if you have a cell phone make sure that
it is off at this point the panel that
is assembled this afternoon is a group
of really extraordinary women all of
whom have made significant contributions
to Emory University and to the role of
women at Emory each has the designation
of America and each has been saluted as
an unsung heroine sometimes quietly and
behind the scenes and sometimes much
more visibly each has worked to make
this
University a better place to work study
and grow it is my privilege to briefly
introduce each of our panelists I will
do this quite simply by giving you their
name and title so that you will begin to
have a sense of who they are and the
varied parts of the University in which
they have served each panelist will in
turn tell you a little more about
herself and the context of the time in
which she arrived at Emory University
this will be followed by a conversation
among the panelists I will begin the
introductions on your right proceeding
around the table dr. Mary Alice flower
professor emeritus of health physical
education and dance dr. young fun some
professor emeritus of medicine dr.
Julianne Davin associate vice president
emeritus for campus life dr. Elizabeth
sharp professor emeritus of medicine and
nursing dr. Elizabeth Connell professor
emeritus of medicine dr. Mary Ann char
bode hon professor emeritus of nursing
professor Brenda Bynum professor of
theatre and drama dr. Dana green dean
emeritus of Oxford College Dean Green
has graciously agreed to moderate the
panel this evening and she will direct
the singing if you will of unsung
stories
Dean green well thank you man I we need
to thank some other people as well
namely man and charity Crabtree who
helped organize this event today so
thank you very much for doing this we're
here as nan has said as women America to
document our perspective on the
university that we've served for many
years and a university that shaped us
very personally over these many long
years we begin with the premise that if
you don't know the past you can't
understand the present and you can't
imagine a new future we're here to
record our past for the sake of the
future our seven panelists arrived at
Emory from different places and at
different times in the university's
history they worked in different schools
and made different contributions but
collectively all of these women have
given more than 200 years of service to
this institution now none of us has been
here for two hundred years herself but
among us I think it's you Mary Alice who
has the greatest longevity so if you
will begin to tell us how and why and
when you came to memory and what you
found when you arrived I Maryalice
Claire I started teaching at Emory in
1958 that was a long time ago I can
assure you they have been many many
changes not only in the physical campus
but also in the college and the
university people ask me why what do you
want to why did you want to come to him
your university and i think i have
several reasons and then people would
always ask when they found out that i
stayed here for 34 years and why did you
stay here for 34 years
and I think some of the reasons are the
same and I'd like to mention a few of
them the first one I needed a job and I
think that might have brought several of
us here but I did need a job I had just
finished getting my master's degree at
the University of North Carolina at
Greensboro I've been teaching in high
school and I wanted to give college
teaching a try so I started looking
around I grew up 40 miles south of
Atlanta excuse me and I had heard about
Emory University all my life not that I
knew much about the college and the
university but I did know a little bit
about the hospital in the medical school
but everybody who talked about Emory it
was always with this glow and they
appreciated Emory and they thought it
was a wonderful place so I when I found
out there was an opening at Emory then I
thought hey that might be the place I
should look into the department chair as
when I was an undergraduate student and
when I was working on my master's knew
dr. Thomas McDonough who was chapter
department at that time and they all
thought he was probably one of the best
physical education people in the country
again I thought that that's certainly a
plus I got here and I have to agree
agree with them mr. McDonald was a
wonderful physical educator when I came
on campus for the interview I was very
impressed with the people from
administration and I was also impressed
with the people in the in the department
of health and physical education one
reason i was so impressed with the
department is that it was one department
that for most of you not being in
physical education back then the
physical education departments were
divided you had men's physical education
department on campus and you had women's
from physical education department on
campus the talk was beginning to start
about combining them and lead us to say
it was not very pleasant talk and fact
it did not make for their good marriage
because the men wanted so much the women
wanted so much but to think here here's
the department that has already done
that
they will not have to go through that
men teach women women teach men could
educational classes I thought what could
be better so that was certainly in the
back of my mind to as i was looking at
schools then I guess I was lucky enough
to get the job that's all I can say I
had felt very lucky to be a part of
Emory fought for 34 years I was here and
I still be still feel very honored to
have been a part of it you'd open you
take a job you sign the contract and it
says you will teach or you will do this
you will do something else so I called
that I sign the contract and I thought I
would be teaching but I got to Emory and
I found that it's not just teaching that
you do in the physical education
department we kept busy in that
department we all talk five or six
classes every day we coached we worked
in intramurals and any time we had a
varsity sporting event we also also took
time out to work with that if we were
timing or whatever we were doing so we
kept busy and people would always say
hey you're better Eddie to go home and
through a four o'clock this afternoon
aren't you would say no not not today
we're not going to quite make it three
or four o'clock and if some of you who
have been here a long time remember Emma
used to sponsor a lot of high school
events and we were always having some
type of athletic high school event on
the campus I'll never forget when we had
the southeastern high school swimming
meet here and there were 400 high school
student swimming at that time all the
scoring was kept by hand paper and
pencil we had no computers then of
course we only messed up one time we
sent one team home with the first-place
trophy and they came in third
so ed Smike if some of you remember it
had to call that team and ask him to
please return the trophy the next day
they did not did not win needless to say
that certain was not one of our best
efforts but but we did try another thing
happened one time that I'd like to just
toss in here because we did have things
like this taking place all the time in
the department I was coaching the
women's tennis team we were going had a
match with west georgia in carrollton so
we left campus about twelve-thirty and
at that time we drove the physical plant
vans if some of you remember the
physical plant vans you can appreciate
this they they were not in the best
condition but here we would go and we
would go down we would have the match
after the match we got a bite to eat and
we start at home Oh about 15 miles out
of Carrollton we had a flat tire so so
of course we got that taken care of and
hit it on our way wait to campus after
we got that we had been traveling
probably about 20 miles and we had the
same tire to go flat so i had to call i
don't know if it was Julian I don't know
what Dean it was to get word to the
dormitories that the that the women
would be coming in so we finally got
home that night about to a 230 then one
day a dream that most of us had had in
the department finally came became a
reality that was in 1983 when the new
physical education was was built I say
new physical education building that
building is 25 years old this week that
doesn't seem possible but with the
Woodruff physical education center was
open and there was an immediate
explosion on campus not only did people
who may be disliked activity they were
even come into the gym so we were very
pleased to get everybody at least coming
over to see the new building
that was that was I guess a dream that
some of us who had been teaching here
for that long never thought would be a
reality as long as we were teaching but
it but it did take place in it just did
wonders for our department not only for
our teaching and our physical education
courses but also in women and men's
athletics of course I guess you can say
from 1983 on the rest of the growth of
what has gone on that building is
actually history because it's just been
unbelievable what has taken place there
is one thing I would like to just brag
about just a little bit before I go much
much farther we did not have any type of
dance program when we came to when I
came to Emory and I felt that Emery
above all educational institutions that
I knew needed a dance department I
thought our students needed the dance I
thought the campus needed the dance so I
think Clyde Parton came this afternoon
to make sure would tell the truth about
all of this but I fought and I pushed
and I fought and I pushed and we began
to get a few dance courses in before we
had the new building but then after we
had the new building we did have a dance
studio and the dance program started
growing in leaps and bounds we had we
were able to hire two professional
people to come in and they certainly did
a good job getting our dance program
started I will say now they're on the
Murray campus a student can receive a
major and a minor in the dance program
they have five full-time dance faculty
on their staff they have a person who
does all of the costuming and it is just
remarkable height is grown of course
they do have all of their own recitals
in the Performing Arts Center they not
only perform here on campus they are
also invited to go all so if the one
thing that that I do have to brag about
I do have to brag just a little
but about about the dance program I
think Parton probably got very tired of
hearing that but I wasn't going to stop
before it did become a reality when I
first started teaching at Emory we had
eight people in the department six men
and two women we did not grow just a lot
until nineteen eighty-three because we
simply did not have a space to to put
other people to put other faculty member
members even though the student body was
growing in leaps and bounds we still did
not have enough spaces in our building
to put another faculty member and to
give you just an example in 1983 well
let me go back in 1958 we taught about
30 to 34 classes in physical education
per quarter then we were still we were
on the quarter system in 1983 the number
had risen to about 70 courses per
semester in 2008 2009 this particular
year in the fall they offered 91 classes
in physical education and in the spring
semester they're offering 78 a few
numbers about athletics in 1958 as I
mentioned there were six people back on
the physical education faculty but they
also did the coaching in 2008 this
school year there are a total of
eighteen varsity sports nine men and
nine women they also offered 25 club
sports the number that participate in
intramurals just unbelievable on the
campus
and I did that was tossed out about what
you might talk about is your social
activity and I thought about this and
being in physical education and in
athletics I've been an activist just as
long as I've been in the profession you
really had to be an activist to get a
lot of things accomplished it took a
long time title nine certainly health in
fact that's what put a silver with the
legality of women being offered the same
as men on college campuses and then a
lot of the women in but in my field
disagreed when the NCAA wanted to take
the women under their umbrella but I was
one of them that thought we should go
that way because I knew that's where the
power was and that's where the money was
and I just felt that's the neat the way
we needed to go and since we have gone
that way all of you people have seen
what happened on college campuses on
professional sports as far as women's
athletics are concerned as I started off
I said I was I was very lucky to get a
job here at at Emory I still feel very
much that way I don't think I would have
enjoyed being anything else as much as I
did at Emory thank you thank you very
much too young fun and we're getting
shorter as we come along shorter time I
went to university Michigan for medical
school for my medical degree my first
year I met a guy who studied
pharmacology and eventually I married
him that start to Steven Holtzman see
right down there and we married last
year of medical school my medical school
and he got a PhD in pharmacology
and I never heard about Emory until he
offered a post out job so we came down
direct from Michigan all the way down to
atlanta and in 1969 and I he could offer
as a postdoc and I come down to look for
my internship and I was interviewed by a
medical doctor in medicine and he said
well you do research I say yes you have
very good credential but are you not
going to medicine internal medicine you
can't anesthesiology right I say yes he
said we don't need you I was so sad that
was a Friday night rainy day and I went
went back to hotel and the next morning
saturday we're supposed to leave and I
was getting fortunately to my husband
say maybe we should go to the hospital
would take a look if we can find anybody
I was lucky enough to find me that the
chairman of anesthesiology department
dr. Steinhaus he's 92 years old now and
he and I we talked about two hours and
the results is he already filled up to
internship position we say if you choose
me first i will create position for you
so the rest is history by anyway when I
was a junior faculty and the he made me
to start a service that's a hospital
service subsequently I start a total
five service was in the hospital one
thing Wesley words and a three in MV
tourists at the center and Emory because
I'm the only female on fabric around
that time made me very strong I want to
be a real good physician so I stood up
to the surgeons because they respected
me I bear their patient out if they are
patient bleeding the patient has a
trouble I bear them out because my
philosophy is I'd like to treat the
patient the way I like to
treated and so it makes me a good n
demonstrator because I style the service
and also a researcher I did a lot of a
clinical research since the clinic my
clinica doesn't encourage it for
research work so I say well in that case
for basic science wise I cannot do
research but I'd like to do some product
research so I did a lot of research on
my patient and all my patient positive
participating research they really enjoy
what we did you give them new anesthetic
next time they come back they ask for
more I said no FDA had approved this yet
you know something like that so thanks
to dr. Steinhaus encouragement I become
a first female professor in my
department more than 50 years of history
and because my husband encouragement we
have very few female faculty in medical
school and I was mentoring medical
student male or female no discrimination
and also especially the minority during
my tenure and I also mentoring for some
junior faculties especially minorities
and who were junior them then I was like
a surgery anesthesiology department and
even in the pharmacology to pump so I
really enjoy what I've done and the Emmy
trained me to be a strong character and
also a good physician as well as a good
administrator Thank You Julian I'm
Giuliana 'then my tenor at Emory not my
tenure but my tenor began in nineteen
fifty eight when I arrived as a student
much against my older brothers
protestations he was by then in medical
school told my parents don't let
Giuliana
I to Emory college because she will not
be accepted she's not Emory material
that Emery I had a quota on the number
of undergraduate women and I was not
going to be acceptable within that quote
long story short I got in and found that
what he said was true that women had
been so recently admitted into the
college I think it was 5553 ginger and
this was 58 right and the professor's
really didn't want to call upon the
women in the class not that there were
very many of us at a time there were
about 1700 men in the college of arts
and sciences and 300 women so there may
have been five or six of us in any given
humanities or science classes the you
would wave your hand wave your hand and
finally give up because you knew you
were going to have to settle for a be
regardless of how much you knew well I
was lucky enough to get through all of
that graduate go away do some other
things go to graduate school come back
in nineteen seventy the Vietnam War was
really kicking up every students were
protesting in just short of violent ways
they were setting fires to the trash
cans in the quadrangle up and down by
the buildings they held the president
the then president hostage for nine
hours trying to get him to get the Board
of Trustees to sign the paper a petition
to give to coca-cola that maybe
coca-cola could do something about the
war and stopping the Vietnam War at
least make a big fuss about this the
Atlanta media was full of this there was
a new dean of women a new dean of men
the previous ones had resigned or
retired and everything seemed to be in
chaos out here so as an interested
alumni came out to see the new the then
new dean of women
and since eighty percent of the
undergraduate population was Greek
related sororities and fraternities I
said look I was Greek I'll work with the
sorority girls and try to settle things
down through them to the paternity guys
well she said can you come to work
Monday morning I said I don't need a job
i'm working at georgia state I'm in my
doctoral program and she said well I
need you here so I came sure enough
there were only three hundred women
still in the college there were up to
five women in the medical school up to
five were admissible Bob do you remember
those days maybe they would take two or
three in 1972 all that changed the law
school had no women on their faculty
neither did Kammler School of Theology
to get into the graduate school if you
were a woman either your daddy paid or
your husband paid there was no financial
aid for women dr. Greene can attest to
that she finished in 67 with her PhD in
the ILA it was really a dismal situation
for women there were so many glass
ceilings you couldn't even see up that
high to see whether you could get
through them or not there was a senior
administrator a male who was it's part
of his duties to keep those uppity women
and quiet on the campus that
administrative women I was junior
administrative of course but there were
senior faculty women who were beginning
to kick up a little sand about unequal
salaries and the things that were
finally solved in the early through
legislation in the early 70s and
throughout the rest of the city's the
entry of dr. Jim Laney as president in
76 really changed the tone on this
campus he did a lot of things to resolve
in equities among students and funding
for athletics and residential
availability for women's students and
married student housing and so on so it
got to be a different climate why did I
stay here so on through the 90s you know
with the increased enrollment with that
legislation that passed in 72 that said
that the feds were going to rescind your
funding if you did not accept admissible
students regardless of gender national
origin sexual orientation and all the
things that that covered indeed women
students begin in this increasing
enrollment onslaught it was really
amazing we had to scurry and Bill more
dorms excuse me residential facilities
you know to accommodate and this
increasing influx by the 80s the College
of Arts and Sciences was over fifty
percent female as was the law school in
the mid to late eighties as in the 90s
the medical school became and certainly
the Graduate School in the theology
school nursing school began to admit men
you know much over the protestations of
some of the senior faculty women in the
nursery school the dental school which
closed in the yeas produced one of our
most outstanding women alumni Marilyn
Morgan dr. Morgan is here today and is a
strong supporter of women's concerns you
know the issues that we had were soon
resolved by senior male administrators
and and the influx of female senior
administrators it was so hard for us to
find mentors in the 70s and early into
the 80s we had people senior women who
nurtured us but they were not free to
mentor us and we began to identify
wonderful mentors we were able to learn
to mentor we found and recognizing
mentors among senior men who nurtured us
lord I mentored so many students
throughout the university who were male
that more of them stay in touch with me
now than the females whom I mentored
they're out and mentoring others you
know so it's been a great ride for me it
was the perfect time
place my father always told us children
my brothers and I we were growing up
don't ever go to work for money find
some people who are being of service to
others and if you respect what they're
doing seeking find a way to join them
the money will follow I found people
being a service it challenged my
potential I learned a whole lot and
enjoyed all of it so daddy was right
thank you very much thank you I'm Alyssa
sharp and I came to Emory in 1970 I will
preface this by saying that I am a nurse
midwife and at that time nurse midwifery
was still very sparsely distributed
through the United States and certainly
there was no nurse midwife in Georgia
that was practicing and the closest
nurse midwifery was in Mississippi when
i came here in 1970 and it was really
pretty much luck that i got here and
that is because in 1970 dr. Thompson
chairman of the department and Newton
lon vice chair and with great interest
in nurse midwifery because he had worked
with nurse midwife spend the medical
director of nurse-midwifery at Johns
Hopkins Hospital Johns Hopkins
University and he had always said I came
here with the understanding that at some
time when it was ripe when he was
possible we would have a nurse midwifery
service and I had been a student of dr.
Thompson's in Baltimore when I was a
Yale student it went down to Hopkins for
the summer clinical experience what
actually happened that was luck was that
there was to be a speaker at a symposium
on nurse midwifery a nurse midwife who
wasn't able to come and they asked me to
come dr. Thompson brought together
professionals medicine nursing social
work variety of people and business
people and lawyers to a continuing
education program symposium about nurse
midwifery he wanted to test the climate
to see if it would be possible to
introduce nurse midwifery in 1970
and as it turned out I spoke at the
conference and saw dr. long and they
were talking about yes they probably
would move ahead and they would be
recruiting and I announced that I had
just resigned from the faculty but for
the upcoming year at Yale University
School of Nursing and I had been a
graduate of that program in nursing it'd
were free and had worked on the faculty
before and after my doctorate so over
about an 11 year span I had been very
involved with Yale and loved Yale but
the reason I was making a change was
that the yale-new Haven Hospital did not
have enough obstetric patients for
faculty medical students residents and
nurse midwifery students and faculty and
I wasn't that old in the profession and
I had not had years and years of
experience and I really felt that I
needed to be in a location or in a
setting where I could practice what I
was going to be teaching or was teaching
so that's why I was making a shift and
so I came down for interviews and
thought that things would be really
wonderful there was a real need for help
in obstetrics in that time at nineteen
seventy when the number of patients at
Grady Hospital were well into the 7000
80s on the obstetric service and there
were not enough residence and faculty to
deliver or to be attendance at the birth
of all the women and they desperately
needed help the residents needed help
and also dr. long and dr. Thompson felt
that it would be helpful for the
learners to see what normal birth was
about and what the care could be with
family centered nursing the nurse
midwives certainly promoted so we were
to start a service we were to teach
medical students we were eventually to
start a nurse midwifery educational
program so i left Yale and came down in
1970 and actually as I look back on it
when you asked how it went when I came
and what was here as probably all you
know the medical school
has for many many years been responsible
for the health care of patients at Grady
Memorial Hospital and our Chairman
ecology obstetrics was very concerned
about their health that the prematurity
rate needed to be reduced maternal
mortality neonatal deaths very concerned
about the situation here at Grady but he
was also involved nationally and on the
President's Council for looking at how
to reduce prematurity so we had really a
very excellent service with a strong
mission here and more far-reaching my
coming of course was sort of shaky
because in this state in many states in
the south and even throughout the
country over the years there had been a
real effort to decrease or two as some
people said eliminate the lay or granny
Midwife particularly in the south at
where it was very popular before
hospitals developed and roads were able
to be traveled and women could get to
the hospital so many many women were
delivered by lay midwives in this state
and others and supervised by the Health
Department so there was some concern
about negativity towards what I
represented the confusion about a
midwife you know attended births in the
home versus a nurse midwife who was
going to be in a hospital working in
collaboration with physicians as it
turned out there was such fine
introduction of the nurse midwives at
Grady and also of me in the University I
remember coming down for interviews
being interviewed by the President the
Vice President Health Sciences the
administrator of the hospital Mary woody
director of nursing at Grady was a
nationally known nurse who was very
familiar with the development of
advanced what we now call advanced years
practice of which nurse midwifery has
been a part in many educational
institutions so there was a and I was
introduced to people at the State Health
Department at the clinics to county
clinic health departments so I was
really introduced and the way was paved
for me to come and then to employ nurse
midwives in a nurse midwifery service
that eventually had 23 nurse midwives
and we were doing approximately a third
of the bursts at Grady so we really did
meet a need and eventually started an
educational program but i think it was
with the very careful introduction and
with the respect and expectation that
this oddity a nurse midwife coming down
would be integrated into the service and
it was novel i remember when i was
coming out of the delivery room after
conducting to be a participating in the
first birth one that i had helped a
mother have her baby and i put the baby
on the mothers abdomen and that shocked
people and then I you know everything
was finished and I went to go out the
door and as I lucked out i knocked
people down because about four or five
people had been peering in the little
window to see what this nurse midwife
was doing and then of course they were
talking later about what I did do which
was you know like show the mother the
baby and put it on her abdomen helped
put it the breast the for breastfeeding
and the various things that we were
doing as nurse midwives that were
perceived as different so I really have
fond memories of those days and then as
time went on yes indeed we started an
educational program and nurse midwifery
developed throughout the state and it's
very satisfying to know that today
Georgia ranks second in the number of
bid wife conducted bursts in the whole
country so it says that what we started
seemed to have a ripple effect
throughout the state which leads me to
say oh and I've you on a comment because
I know that nursing is here in nursing
is very important to me because nursing
is my roots and I when I was interviewed
here at the time the nursing school did
not see nurse midwifery as nursing they
saw it as little doctoring but I would
not come without an appointment in the
School of Nursing all
my primary appointment was in the school
of medicine and over time the nursing
school became interested in an
educational program and so we were very
very satisfied in being able to
eventually accomplish that and and then
a dual degree program and the other
thing I would say about the overall
experience is there was always something
new to explore and I see Bob DeHaan here
who was involved in starting the
exploring and ethics enter Emory and
Emory University and the department
School of Medicine were very open to us
as faculty exploring different avenues
that might be important and have
relevance so I always found there was
something new on the horizon to do and
and I'm happy to say the nurse midwifery
services still its existence at Grady
which is remarkable remarkable because
so many of the large hospitals have
closed their services Thank You Liz
ready I came here in 1981 because i got
married in 1980 which you might find an
interesting statistic I married Howard
Tatum dr. Howard Tatum who invented the
IUD that prevented more unwanted
pregnancies than any other form of
contraception and wee-bey both in
working and family planning for years
and so we were kind of a natural team so
we got married had a one terribly long
probably just a few months and we were
sitting in a plain one day and he said
to me Betty I want to get out of New
York he had been at Rockefeller
University for about 16 years he said
I'm sick of shoveling snow and I want to
go south and I said okay and so we
decided we ought to look at what we
wanted and so we may list wanted a good
medical school wanted a good faculty
what a good support staff including
particularly nurses and we wanted to
have a good patient
situation so we could continue to do
research and write papers and we wanted
a good Airport because we were both
doing an awful lot of work
internationally so if we made the list
and then we reached into the pocket in
the plane seat in front of us pulled out
a map and we picked out five southern
cities and then we line the five cities
up against our list and we decided who
was obvious Emory was where we wanted to
go so we looked into it and Anne
Thompson as he seems to come in our
lives here and and Howard had been
faculty together at to Tulane and since
he and I had done a lot of work
internationally we knew a lot of people
at CDC and at that time you had to come
and make presentations so we did we gave
talks at every we gave talks at CDC and
the faculties of both said yep we'd like
to have you come but we were heading out
to Africa at that point to do some work
and we had not been approved by the
board of trustees and so while we were
there we don't even there a couple of
days and Dan Thompson cabled us and he
said well the faculty has decided that
you're worthy and so the people at CDC
said yeah yeah you're worthy to so there
we were and we came came to Emory now I
arrived with to sort of unusual things I
arrived as a full tenured professor
which was pretty unusual in those days
and I also arrived with a husband and
that was also extremely unusual because
this was sheer nepotism for many many
years to have a husband and a wife
arrived in the same faculty in the same
medical school was very much unheard of
for many many years in my experience two
men we get full professorship and the
women would get assistant professor
sometimes if they're lucky associate
professor and rarely could you end up in
the same department so I felt that this
was really a very fortunate thing that
we were able to come together we had
everything that we wanted we went down
the list and we decided yes that this is
what we wanted and things began to
change in a lot of ways even before we
got here and some of us has been alluded
to when I was in medical school there
were very few of us we were a rare breed
and there were very few medical students
interns resident faculty members who had
ovaries they were an unusual and it's
rare and unusual a commodity and we
didn't always get the best of our work
ethic I can remember very well going
back a ways when I was at an American
Cancer fellow the first fellow with
ovaries they'd ever had and I proved
what I was doing because I was eight
months pregnant at the time that i
started my my my fellowship and i had no
room and i want to tell you i was quite
a sight sleeping on a gurney in the
hallway eight months pregnant now things
began to change even before we got here
and the same thing happened at Emory
during the time since we arrived and
happily so many places including every
many departments of ob-gyn now are more
than half women and many many minorities
are coming into the field where they did
not exist back in the days when I was a
medical student so as we look back over
the years we thought about it and we
thought about our lists and we said yeah
we made the right decision
it was Thank You Betty ma'am well i
arrived in atlanta in 1970 and i had
moved from New England and I was
involved in consciousness-raising groups
of there around childbirth and and I was
really wanted to be part of the
revolution in childbirth and I moved to
Atlanta I had three children but I heard
that Emery had a master's degree in
maternal and infant health and I thought
well this is a good credential that
might help me and I was teaching
childbirth classes and so I enrolled at
Emory and I thought what three children
maybe I'll just do one course at a time
so I was accepted and I did one course
and then one of the faculty and it might
have been dr. O'Shea said you know if
you come full time we have funding so I
loved up and I came back I came back the
next year and went two years and
finished my master's degree in maternal
and infant health and at that time
childbirth revolution with hadn't
happened I went around and visited
obstetricians and to tell them that I
wanted to have had them advertised my
childbirth classes and they said oh no
no no southern women don't want to do
that you know we have this magic drug
they won't feel anything and I thought I
don't think though so after I graduated
I worked in a private practice for
several years and I did find that all
the patients in the practice wanted to
have natural childbirth and not all but
a lot of them and they wanted to come to
childbirth classes and so I did that for
several years and about that same time
dr. Sharpe started the midwifery program
at Emory and I thought oh rats i was
just two years three years too early but
fortunately the they decided that they
would take one or two postmasters nurses
into the midwifery program
so that's how i got into midwifery and i
finished that in 79 and i went back to
that private practice because then I
thought you know midwives it was we had
a lot of press surely in this private
practice that pretty soon I'll have
hospital privileges and I'll deliver all
these women who came to see me well that
didn't happen the head of ob-gyn at that
Hospital said over my dead body will we
have nurse midwives delivering at my
hospital and he was fairly young so that
was depressing I didn't see this
happening and I had at that time had
four or five years experience and i
worked at grady on the weekends getting
deliveries under my belt as they say and
fortunately dr. Sharpe had an opening in
the nurse midwifery program and invited
me to join the faculty which I did and I
was there for almost 20 years and so
things changed in that hospital where I
couldn't get privileges I think the
nurse midwives deliver about fifteen or
twenty percent of all the babies now and
at Northside Hospital which is the
largest hospital maternity hospital
nurse midwives deliver close to forty
percent of the babies and I think that
this dis attests to dr. sharps foresight
in coming here and I'm personally very
grateful that that happened and i
retired from emory in two thousand and
then went to the cdc for five years
thank you Mary on Brenda my name is
Brenda bynum and i came here in 1983 and
i stood on the shoulders of these
goddesses who come before me by the time
I got here the glass ceiling for my
discipline was much lower than it was
for women I was in theatre studies and
the founding year of the department of
theatre studies at Emory was the
academic year 1982 1983 I was primarily
in the professional theatre at that
I'm even though I had already taught
from time to time at three separate
universities I was hired to be in a play
to play Hecuba Queen Hecuba in the
spring of that first season and the MGM
theater which is here now was completely
flooded with construction dirt and sand
and in order to make that prediction
authentic at the end of that production
the head of the department and the
director of that play asked me would I
stay on and begin teaching and I said of
course I lived in the neighborhood it
was perfect so I replaced a man whose
contract was not renewed so that I could
begin teaching I think that's cool and I
stayed here for 17 years retiring in two
thousand the department's had a very
slow start outside the theater all we
had was in office the Office of the
Director classrooms were where we could
find them i spent one very memorable
semester teaching my class in the
visiting men's locker room behind the
basketball court in woodruff gym i
taught several number of semesters in
various places in the wood with jim none
other quite so aromatic as that there
were times when my home was closer to my
classroom than my office on campus
because our department really didn't
come together until we were lucky enough
to get moved into one of those World War
two barracks which used to be over there
where schwartz center is now we stayed
there happily for many years until the
b-school decided that the rich building
was uninhabitable and moved into
goizueta and we got the rich building
and they're still there and happy to
have it so it was quite an odyssey it
was my good fortune coming in at the
very bottom as the first faculty member
to be able to build helped build that
department in a way that you don't often
have such opportunities to
to be on the very ground floor it was a
terrific thing for me I was happy to be
there and now i will say that that
department I called over to ask they now
have 15 faculty members and almost 70
majors and minors so things have turned
out very well indeed thank you from
other than the nursing school I was the
first woman Dean permanent woman Dean of
any college of Emory that has changed
happily in the last couple of years
we've got a woman Dean of the Graduate
School end of the theology school and
obviously of the nursing school as well
i am going to not say any more about
myself because the President's
Commission on the status of women has
already done recorded my reflections and
we want to use this time to to have our
panelists share some of their other
thoughts now you all have been here for
many many years you've talked about the
institution in what ways has Emory
enriched and changed your lives during
this time that you were here live I had
just jump in yeah I think I was you know
beginning to talk about that yah spoke
earlier is that clearly I knew that
there were certain things that I had to
do you know being you know have a nurse
midwifery service develop an educational
program and as a faculty there was still
the latitude to be highly involved in my
professional national professional
organization as well as the local route
but nationally and to participate fully
in that over the years there was the
opportunity to participate in things
that came up at Emory I already
mentioned the ethics center and work
when we developed the dual degree
program that Mary hall and others in the
faculty at the School of Nursing worked
with dr. Ganga rose on it put me in
kutch and my doctorate is in public
health so it was a nice
so then I was involved with the faculty
and the program's over there and
particularly a maternal and child health
and then there were opportunities to
move outside the university to be a
consultant to the state as the state was
developing nurse midwifery projects so I
felt that as a faculty member it was a
it was expected I mean it seemed him
just be natural annex and then seemed to
be of interest to others on the faculty
into dr. Thompson and School of Nursing
Dean and so forth that that we reach out
so that we were able to do a variety of
things that we felt needed to be done
and yet it made it very exciting for me
to have always new things to work on
develop and then to see others coming up
working in the areas that you know we
had sort of gotten started and I was
delighted when Marianne walked in and
said she would you no wonder she could
be a part of the faculty I was thrilled
so that you know some came back to teach
on the faculty and the current director
of the nurse midwifery program was in
our very first nurse midwifery class but
she had practice in other areas was
involved in the first and only birth
center in Atlanta so she was certainly
prepared to teach so I would say that I
had a very interesting life as a faculty
member and felt that we had been
successful and that was very satisfying
to me and then to be involved in other
things so I felt that I gained a lot by
being a part of Emory and having the
kinds of things I cared about really
working and then exploring new vistas
for me I'll jump in here I began to talk
about and then decide to cut my remarks
shorter I learned the difference between
nurturing and mentoring I'd said that
the stage was set that senior faculty
women found it very difficult to meant
or the younger faculty are the younger
or junior administrators because there
is so much intervention among the men
they didn't want the women to get
together in other words so we got a lot
of nurturing from these senior women and
not much mentoring until dr. laney kind
of cleared the air in the mid-70s here
I'm the last thing of women that Emery
will have had I pray pray that will be
so I also pray that the mentoring that I
received and learned how to give as i
said earlier not only to the men and to
the women but also to the men students
that that is still going on in that that
senior men or mentoring the younger
women faculty and students and vice
versa with senior women mentoring
younger the younger male faculty and
such it's just so healthy you know
nurturing is where you know ginger Cain
who is a great student and a leader and
very innovative and creative as a
student I would say to her great job
ginger powder on the back that was a
great talk you gave to the sorority last
night and so forth keep up the good work
that is wonderful nurturing when you
really mean it I ever mentoring is
picking up the phone and calling
somebody call Linda books in the library
and say I have a student here who's a
freshman he needs to make some sorority
money to help her team and all this
stuff have you got a little job over
there and Linda book says well Center
over here and we'll talk to her that's
mentoring Linda books hired her and now
gingers University archivist you know
there's story after story of outcomes of
mentoring and the healthiest and most
appropriate place for it to begin to
turn old children into young adults is
on the college campus and to turn young
adults into mature proactive creative
people is within a university community
so I thank you marie a lot for enriching
my life
that why i actually agree and i was able
to in my years at emory really explore
avenues that dealt with women so early
on i got involved with the women's
center and this is right after it
started maybe in 94-95 and one area that
in a conversation with ali that we we
were talking about it was at the same
time that the American Academy of
Pediatrics came out and said all babies
should be breastfed until their
one-year-old and we were chatting we're
thinking these women who are coming back
to Emory and where are they going to
pump their breast and how is that going
to happen here and so we thought about
it and started something or open
something found a room in the trailer
and designated a nursing nest and bought
a breast pump for women and it became a
very heavily used area and not only did
women come there to breastfeed I mean to
pump their breast that their partners or
husbands would bring babies at lunch
time and so the mothers could feed the
babies during the day prior to this I
think faculty would would not have a
problem breastfeeding or pumping their
breasts in their offices but we found
out that graduate students and staff use
the restrooms and that was a major and
let us to look into this and I'm happy
to say that the President's Commission
on the status of women took this cause
up and they now have a lactation support
program which is Emory University policy
4.91 there are 16 areas designated on
Emery's campus for lactating mothers
every building every new building has to
have a designated lactation space so
when we think about changes and that was
one major change with that helping
during my tenure here I think one of the
nicest things about being at Emory was
to have a chance to continue interest
that we came with an advance them look
at different methods of birth control
and allow women to choose how they would
spend their lives to have control over
their reproduction meant so much two
women having started clinics in new york
city and the barrios i live for years
with watching what happened to women who
had no control over their lives and i
must admit there were quite a few
agretti who had had very very bad years
until we gave them the opportunity to
control their fertility go back to
school get degrees and it was just so
exciting to see things that happen to
women who suddenly were able to be in
control of their lives so that was very
important and also the ability to run
programs to collaborate with CDC and
places around the world where we knew
people very supportive i ran for 10
years a program here that some of the
people here talked at on family planning
and everything was very supportive and I
think was interesting to watch not only
the women but the women going through
training we were a little bit combative
you know we had to be not just as good
as the men we had to be better and it
was interesting to watch the psychology
of how things went along I remember
going to the American College of ob-gyn
and had four women my generation sitting
one side and for sitting on the other
and I suddenly realized times had
changed we were combative they were not
they didn't have to be they had moved
into the mainstream and we were there at
the birth and it was very exciting I
would like to say that Emory and the
women's center and my department
supported me over the years in the
development of all
a dozen original plays and performance
pieces based on the lives of real women
all of which were presented here
somewhere through the years and that was
a remarkable opportunity for me which I
would not have had I hesitate to say in
the real world but that's you know what
I'm talking about I was mentored by two
male when's my chairman former chairman
and my former vice chairman and because
Emery has so few female in on the
faculty around my time and the day there
is a few but mostly they they won the
work of the family they don't want a lot
of work and they don't want the research
data one day there's they don't do that
you know something sometimes they want
to work part time since I'd that but i
think if you want do the job you better
do well so I work like twice or three
times harder than some male colleague so
you stand up you stood up among the your
colleague and that of course once you
made yourself reputation you know the
surgeon usually they always blame my
anesthesiologist and the complainants
easier you guys probably know about this
and I even stood up him from the surgeon
and tell them what to do tell them how
well they should take care of the
patient you know and when time when
certain Jesus he wasn't a very good
surgeon he left a me subsequently and he
came to me he said you know young found
surgeons kept on the ship I told him I
say if you work having them a ship the
ship son hahahaha so if I back off
because he then made a lot of mistake
during the surgical procedures so I put
in my office told him you know you
should have done there you should have
you know you're sure this concept which
they've seen your colleague or whatever
you know so so that settles that by
anyway so you know you the emory you
know waiting i have a nice female and
but they make me as a strong character
and to protect my patient to put you
know to to mchenry even look about it
you know that she reminds me of how
difficult it was when you first start
getting out and doing things because
after i came to emory i started getting
on fda committees and running him and
doing this and doing that and it took me
a year or two to get over the fact that
i was probably being offered these
things because i had over it and i think
a lot of women go through this that they
realized in the very beginning they
don't give a damn about me i have
ovaries and they want women in those
slots and it's a curious psychological
phenomenon that women go through from
feeling they've been bought two feeling
that they're there because they want you
there because you're worth something and
that's very much the same experience
that you you mentioned sit very curious
phenomenon I've got to say that I never
had some of these feelings and and in
that building I was working in mr.
McDonough was one of the kindest most
gentle persons I've ever known and he
always stood up for the women always
stood up for the women Clyde part and
trained under mr. McDonough and so Clyde
was very much that way and I didn't have
to feel that I had to fight my way out
of anything go I did have to fight for a
dance program but simply didn't have a
place for him and I still thought it was
very important but I don't know I guess
participating against some some guys and
some of the sports that I did when I was
growing up I just never had this feeling
I just never had to to feel like I've
gotta fight against that man to get any
place I want to go maybe I was lucky I
you should have gone to medical school
the lamb acute Yeah right map like that
I think we mentioned that women were
only here in admitted to Emory college
1953 and clearly the numbers that in the
subsequent decades were so few for women
and so each of you was a pioneer in many
many different ways having different
kinds of experiences are there any other
things that you want to have recorded
for this history your your perspective
on this is unique in the history of
memory so now is now is the moment if
there are other aspects of your
experience as a woman or how you've seen
the experience for women change at Emory
it would be good to to to record that
and obviously we've we've spoken about
this some are ready
I promised that I wasn't going to say
anything but maybe I maybe I should I
came in 1967 they were not a financial
aid for women was very very limited and
I can remember being assigned though I
was on the ILA Graduate Council and
being assigned e the odious task of
going to a faculty meeting and trying to
get the faculty to explain why women
were not given financial aid and I
remember one of my great mentors the
Austrian Gregor ziba I don't know if any
of you remember him pounding on the
table saying that this was not a boy
scout camp here and we we would do
things the way we wanted to do them but
we felt we felt nonetheless supported by
individual faculty members and somehow
made it through and it was a great
pleasure to come back for myself to
Emory to see the work that all of you
had done for the last 30 years in this
interim period in making Emory a very
very different place for for women so as
brenda has acknowledged you all as
goddesses I do too because I could see
thee when I came back in 99 I could see
the great changes that had been made any
other comments on your perspectives on
Emery your history here how Emery
affected your lives I think of over
those years and I am really changed I
think Emily become more open-minded ever
been I during my time and there was
first black mayor
student I think his name's of Hamilton a
homes right now homes and that later he
become the first orthopedic doctor and I
worked with him and that was that was
but he passed away right yes better
conductor greedy yes blanket medical
Directorate Grady Alison emigrated to I
I had a contact with him up when you
work in Emory hospital you know so
things change you know I the reason I
like to mentor a lot of different
minority student you know medical
student I did a lot of work with you
Nora t medical student as well as
faculty you know things like because i
am first generation immigrant and i was
born in mainland china and came to this
country and I made it legally okay and I
I say if I can do it so does everybody
else so you know but Emery used to be
you know very very few minority people
you know I'm a female don't even mention
about anyway so now seems to change and
we have a excellent new resurgent house
black african-american you know ended we
have a accent dermatologist who is the
african-american and I think that's
great you know Amy become better in a
very place for everybody to work and I
think that's very nice not only just for
female i think the other thing that's
changed and certainly changed at emory
and in general is the feeling that we
can do things that we didn't do before I
when I was coming out of residency I was
told make sure you get into dermatology
or pediatrics I wanted to be a general
surgeon and I was told it's bad enough
you're a woman for heaven sakes don't
try to break into any surgical specialty
and so I didn't I did got to be a cancer
fellow so I got to do a lot of big
surgery but still in OBGYN this is
another thing I think has changed the
nursing attitudes have changed our team
I always used to say every year in my
clinics I fire a doctor and hire a nurse
and the care gets better and better and
it did it really did so I think we've
watched the progression of women it not
only numbers but in what they're doing
as you look around boy there are a lot
of women now to orthopedics in general
surgery and neurosurgery I was totally
unheard of and to watch this blossom out
at every at a lot of other places speech
relief for very exciting rewarding you
know the background on that Betty and I
did my dissertation in a study that you
know that be a whole nother seminar here
however the more invasive the procedure
the higher paying the specialty ran the
white gate keepers of the specialty
training programs white-haired
gatekeepers for the most part wanted to
steer the women into the lower paying
specialties such as child psychiatry
Pediatrics son dermatology Family
Planning Group OBGYN was at that time
very high paying through the 50s 60s and
early 70s and then all of a sudden the
liability got so great that it dropped
down and women began to enter a greater
frequency but the more invasive the
procedure for that specialty the higher
plane no it's interesting I did a lot of
running around the country and talking
and doing TV and stuff and I learned
that there's a very interesting change
occurring when a woman went into
practice in a group she had the number
of patients in one year it took the
average male three years to achieve and
I had a lot of male sort of stuffy
professors who say women have no place
in ob/gyn and I say women like to go to
woman and he said no they don't they
really just they really they don't trust
women they'd rather they go to men and I
must admit when obviously general
practitioner our patients split at the
waist I took them from the waist down
and my husband took him from the waist
up so it really was a a major major
difference well um I want to thank you
all we we probably also need to thank
Allah crown for dreaming up this
designation of unsung unsung heroines
because um these women really have made
enormous gifts to this university and I
think we need to thank them we invite
you to come down to Brooks Commons
downstairs to join us for a little
reception and a chance to interact with
all of these unsung heroines so done sir
done son we've been done son yourself if
you like yeah